the very first thing before we get into
the conversation is I've put together a
little something with some of the the
photos that that I liked the most from
the large set that Fred shared with us
and I want to just sort of say a few
things over it so this is 85 photos in
365 seconds that I've put together for
you and it's going to let us just dive
straight into the work and like I said
I'm gonna just say a couple things over
it to hopefully introduce some of the
themes we're gonna go into tonight is
that is that good Fred you want to say
anything before I launch into that yes
lock the doors don't let this is your
life Fred lion okay so here we go and
Fred lion and San Francisco are two
subjects of the night so we'll start
with these 85 photos in 365 seconds and
we talked about this
how how photography is really all about
time so I'm gonna say a few words and
stir up the themes these postcards from
the past some icons from today's San
Francisco you'll recognize other things
that hint at an age gone by there's
nature and culture and art and commerce
intermingled in a San Francisco we all
know well it was a night like this long
ago let's have a look maybe even gawk
the frame shows the scenes that are old
but maybe new to us while others are
familiar persistent and enduring the
present decontextualized by seeing it
also existed in the past sometimes a
dramatic new vantage point or the same
again and during change that stays the
same but difference cities are like this
stable but dynamic still but in motion
like what we call pace layers here long
now culture in nature up against each
other an entangling of governance and
infrastructure and commerce all those
parts moving in concert and contrast
some things fleeting never to return
others continuous the persistence sets
though costumes may change with fashion
steps on the temporal path to where we
are now even though we're in the same
place all alone but there are odd
artifacts in the midst some are surreal
or real but still strange others seem
banal which makes their details
irrefutable the photos remind us there's
a story to the moment and to each face
and more stories every car connects
lives transit an open window travel
between places between stories stories
frozen in a moment or a trajectory how
did the moment end what happened next
where are they now around the block or
the world
maybe the surreal meeting of the end
meeting the ordinary is actually always
present the iconic object under
maintenance Golden Gate Park Splore II
framed as a sliver beside the fact of
all our humanity a front yard rare in
San Francisco with an unnatural glow
strange things maybe from before you
came to town did you hear about that
accordion house who's this guy there's a
story behind each picture making to
practice choices luck and timing in a
sense we're all in the currents of time
rushing past in youth changing pace as
life goes on our memory is biased two
big occasions so we may miss how sweet
an everyday moment actually is just
another day at work the same old commute
home sweet home
each moment every day open to routine or
epic adventure a photos not worth a
thousand words it's different sublime
the photo brings feelings in between
words so I'll stop the words and just
give you Fred's photos for a little
longer
85 photos in 365 seconds we made it wait
Liam thanks everybody have a great night
and and we end with four iconic San
Francisco shots
these are Fred's skinnies do you wanna
maybe we can you can say a quick word
about skinnies then we'll go back into
the actually it was a an art director
who is working on a new magazine a long
time ago and he had columns vertical
columns he had to fill and he said do
you have any skinny pictures and he said
I said why he said well I have a client
who has some very bad copy and I thought
if we put it if we put a large picture
instead of the bad copy we'd get away
and so I you know these are just crop
beans and I thought hey this is fun and
I kind of like the look of them and
that's a sort of an elegant proportion
and it was a great success and so I've
been making them ever since it's just a
cropping but San Francisco is a very
vertical town mm-hmm and so why not do
vertical pictures it also encouraged me
encouraged me to make a lot of vertical
pictures because I discovered early on
when I was really starving and needed to
I was being paid by page rate and I
discovered that if I shot horizontals
the best I could hope for was a half
page but if I shot vertical I might get
a full page
and so I really learned to shoot a lot
deeper
[Music]